right thank you very much
so I would actually like to thank Pinson
because he did like a great introduction
for the topic that I'm going to talk
about although I think we're gonna play
like good cop bad cop because I want to
go a step further and let a try to
understand Gaussian process in terms of
the patient approach so to say so that's
the idea of the talk and maybe at the
very end I want to focus on how you can
use this a in a concrete use case so I'm
gonna start we say Bayesian linear
regression then I with that will go to
the definition of a Gaussian process as
it is and try to understand and make
sense of it and at the very end I will
let's say give a little bit of detail on
the kernels and how you can use them to
do forecasting so I guess we already
have seen what the normal distribution
is so essentially whenever you have our
random vector it says it has a normal
distribution if the density looks like
this so essentially you have a mean and
a covariance functions which let's say
specifies the location and the shape the
support of the of the multinomial
distribution so here we have two
examples on the left hand side we have
seen how this nice ellipse show how
normal multinomial distribution looks
like it can happen that each of the
components is normal and this will
support actually is an example of
something that is not multivariate so he
can see that the devil is in the details
so I wanna let's say point out some of
these things so let us start with the
basic linear regression so what I do
have here is a around 100 data points
which are generated with random noise
and let's say the moral has intercept 1
and a slope 3 and I just want to know
what's the best fit for that so what I
want to do is get the intercept and the
slope but actually I can do more or aim
for more just by trying to find the
distribution of the parameters in the
patient point of view a
how do I do that well I do that through
the base theorem which says that if a I
have the set of data and I model it as
with the noise then you can find the
parameter distribution as posterior
which is proportional to the likelihood
times the prior that's the Bayesian game
so for the prior of the parameters I'm
going to select a multi normal
distribution which I in this case has
dimension 2 so the intercept and the
slope a and before let's say seeing the
data I'm going to sample from the prior
distribution to see which are the
possibilities that I have so the game is
as follows I have these specific matrix
a 2 and 1/2 which I decided to take
because that's my paranoia and I just
sample for that so I took what sample
from the multinomial distribution that
gave me two values the slope the
intercept and the slope and I draw a
line and I do this many times by
sampling from this multi normal
distribution and where I get is are all
of these lines so these are all the
possibilities and that I can actually
get from the specification of this prior
but now this is just from my prior
knowledge I actually want to see how the
data might affect that and this is going
to be encoded a in what's called the
likelihood function which is essentially
the probability of the data given the
input X and B and it turns out that this
is a multi normal distribution again so
in Bayesian analysis getting the
posterior distribution is sometimes a
not easy and instead of doing the math
you actually sample from it so you can
run a Monte Carlo simulation to try to
estimate the Paseo distribution of these
parameters so what we see here is that
the estimation with the sampling
approach of beta 0 is our 1 1 this okay
and also we have like the standard
deviation saying hey how certain we are
of of getting those values and we are
have something
similar for the for the slope a but the
actually the multinomial distribution
the gosset distribution has such a nice
properties which it's really strange but
a lot of the results can be obtained
analytically so a instead of sampling if
you do a little bit of math just a
little bit then you can show that the
posterior distribution of this parameter
is again a Gaussian and I guess maybe
what it's important is that the mean is
somehow proportional to this product and
maybe you can see that these is
essentially captured in the oilless a
solution of the linear regression
so essentially sitting in the mean and I
know that I had this a analytical
solution well actually I could do this
by sampling just from a this a data I
can just play the same game example from
the normal distribution take two values
that's going to give me an intercept and
a slope and I played the same game and I
plot this in green and we see how all of
these lines actually fit the data much
much better so this is a how we usually
a work the linear regression problem in
the Bayesian setting so if I want to do
inference if I want to do a prediction
then what I need to do is wait the
probability of let's say this new input
point times the probability of the
parameters and take the sum or take the
yeah the the sum of that and again it
turns out that just because of the form
of the multinomial distribution this is
again a multinomial distribution and if
I want to do a prediction I will sample
from that and I was unlucky enough that
actually the prediction point when quite
well to the mean but if it's here within
the credible interval it's fine because
they say that the uncertainty that I
have in my model and this is something
like that says that if you want to do
something that is a polynomial
regression or are nonlinear terms in an
additive way you
and do that and you can do the same
thing so just you need to replace for
example if you want to take a polynomial
instead of having X you will map these
to X and the second component X square
and the third component X cube and you
can actually play the same game and you
get exactly the same results and
independently of the math you see that
at the very end you get some explicit
expressions which seem quite of
mysterious but the only important thing
and this is the main message is that
everything in this problem can be
obtained as the product of fee which is
the embedding or X Sigma the covariance
matrix and another fee these are the
building blocks so you can glue this
thing together to get the posterior a
the predictive distribution of your
linear model so essentially if you have
that you have the solution of your
problem so why not define this as as
some like thing by itself so we define
the covariance function or kernel in
this specific case as a function that
takes two points a and it just apply the
a file to X or you can just think it as
a as a vector in the limit as X in the
linear model multiplied by the
covariance matrix and then multiplied by
Phi of the second point so this is a
real number 3 for whatever and this is
the meaning of the kernel a and we it's
important because it specifies the
solution of your linear model these
little Phi here it's what is called the
kernel trick where I can just embed this
let's say polynomials into X into a
polynomial space but at the very end you
don't care about it itself you just care
about the kernel right so yeah so when I
also first read this the the definition
for a Gaussian process
I was super confused and the reason I
give me this talk is to try to see how
much I can understand this I
and I did want to match the definition
that I found in Wikipedia with some
experiments and I'm going to show you in
a second
so I guess the the moral is that
whenever I give you or someone gives you
a kernel function this actually implies
a distribution of a function so at the
moment this makes not a lot of sense but
we're trying to make sense out of it so
if you go to Wikipedia this is the
notion of Gaussian process so a version
process is a collection of random
variables any of which are finite number
of them have a multinomial distribution
so what a so and it says that you can
have the mean and the covariance is what
it specifies the Gaussian process
properties which is the usual mean the
covariance in the usual case using the
expectation value but I want to just
mention that we already have seen a
Gaussian process and the Gaussian
process is just the linear regression
with this prior so let us see why if I
take a prior which is a normal with mean
zero and Sigma as the covariance matrix
and I take this product with a yeah it
is a fee or even the vector this is a
linear combination of normal
distribution which by definition since
this thing is multi normal is a joint
mod it defines a jointly multinomial
probability so this is a Gaussian
process in this definition it has mean 0
and the covariance given by Wikipedia's
definition actually coincide with the
natural little brick which we define via
a simple linear regression right so this
is an example of a Gaussian process and
now I want to show a why people often
say that the Gaussian process is the
infinite dimensional analog of the
multinomial distribution in this content
of our function spaces but instead of
doing a math I'm going to let's say just
explain you how to sample from a
function so to sample from function is a
really hard because it's these things
are infinite dimensional and you don't
know how to do that but you can specify
a
but just by saying what's the image of
any grid of points so in order to sample
for functions what I do is first I set a
grid of points which I call X X star and
then I do the following thing i define
this matrix capital k a which has each
kernel combination for each point so in
this example I have a point X star and
this is a matrix of dimension K times K
so whenever I sample from this I will
get a eighty point and I draw them here
and this would be one of this iteration
so it turns out that when I sample from
this a in this way the functions that I
get are linear functions but that's not
clear why because a I'm just sampling
from this a multinomial distribution
with this kernel so what it's important
is whenever I give you a different
kernel or the kernel changes this
actually is going to give you different
properties of the sampling function that
you will get hey yeah we haven't seen
the data so we have let's say the same
in a regression problem not the next
thing that we want to use Gaussian
process for is to may I try to find a
fit but this is I guess the key slide on
which instead of sampling from
parameters so here we don't have like
intercept or slope were just sampling
from this multi normal distribution and
it happens in this case that we get a
straight line but given the prior if I
just construct the same a let's say
Gaussian process with mean zero and the
kernel matrix well essentially the same
but just including the training data a I
can now you'd say how I would find the
best fit well I will sample from this
one and then I will take out all of the
lines which don't in my training data so
like if they're really far away check
them out if they're good then just take
them
but we don't need to do that because
we're actually in what we want to do is
to condition on the training set so
instead of ages let's say staying with
this a pure Gaussian process we can
condition on the training data and the
input data and this thing is again a
multi normal distribution
and what it's important is not the
formula but it just just depends on the
kernel so the kernel is capturing
absolutely everything here and if I do
the same game where a sample again I'm
not sampling on parameters but I'm
sampling on functions this is what we
get so if you let's say work out this
formula this is exactly the same these
are exactly the same expressions as the
Bayesian linear regression that exactly
the same the only thing that change was
the point of view on which a I forget
about the parameters and I start
sampling in this patient way in a space
of functions and that for me is when I
began understanding what a Gaussian
process was actually doing but then you
have a new universe open up for you
because as we seen in the previous talk
the selection of the kernel a gives you
different type of curves here for your
Gaussian process so the first one is a
so there's a su of kernel functions and
this is ones which have somehow an
interpretation so the first one is just
the one that we have seen for the linear
model which is called the dot product
kernel and actually you can take powers
of it to generate a high order
polynomials as we've seen before and
then we have this square exponential
which is just taking the the exponential
of the differences and actually one can
prove the following if you take your
linear regression with this a polynomial
terms like X X square X cube and you
take all of the polynomials the kernel
that you will get from this linear
regression in the limit is this one
so the a square exponential can be
thought as the natural curve coming from
a linear regression which infinite
polynomials and that's why hey all of
these lines drawn from this Gaussian
process are really smooth because a
natural question is like how smooth
these lines are going to be because
we've seen in the interaction between
the points depend that all of these
kernels they depend essentially on the
difference it doesn't need to be like
this but if you want for whatever
application control the smoothness then
you want to go for something which is a
may be a rational quadratic kernel and
this has another intuition or like a way
of thinking about it so it actually it's
a weighted sum of square Exponential's
right and as we have seen a you can also
model periodic signals by introducing
periodic functions like the sine
function so let us try to see a example
on which these it can be applied in
nonlinear setting so it's not important
about the the function that I'm taking
it's a sum of a sine function but if you
are giving these trying to fit a linear
model by just say of time to get the
features like is it like cubic or like a
polynomial or than for well actually
this is where Gaussian processes can
come really handy so what I'm doing here
is just generating random noise out of
this nonlinear curve and I want to see
how I could feed the points so it's
essentially the same game I have my
prior and the kernel that I'm going to
use is this square exponential so
there's a little bit of code you can
opportunely not see but I will share
this and I promise you you can actually
run these notebooks and a what is
important is that I'm running a sample
from this distribution here have 80
points where I want to test and then I
do the selection and I plot the images
and you see that in this Gaussian
process we get a lot of these a complex
and curly curves
in the fact that there's some curvature
and complexities just because this is a
different kernel a and different kernels
gives different natures are on the
course space so these are all your
possibilities so now let's see how let's
say the joint distribution looks like
and as we have seen a the kernel just
depends on the differences and that's
why if I plot a heat map of this a joint
of the covariance of the joint a
distribution this is how it looks but
actually were interested in the zero
square on which is the new data coming
and the only thing I need to do is to
condition this is how the new a
covariance a matrix would look like this
is not really interesting what is
interesting is this that we never high
condition a with this in the joint
distribution with this kernel I get a
really really nice fit and there's no
parameters here this is a nonparametric
way but it is a nice a let's say method
to let's say do a density estimation or
model is not a linear signals and a
maybe I didn't comment on that but all
of these kernels actually depend on
parameters and these parameters actually
are also important in your feed you
cannot just take the one that you like
the most because this will have an
impact on the dispersion on functions so
if I take these a parameters let's say
in a different way I'm gonna get
different fit so L for discussion for
this square exponential is somehow the
scale so if I take it like really big or
really low then this is going to let's
say define how complex or how flexible
migration process is even if it's really
really smooth so there are various ways
of selecting these hyperparameters I
don't want to go into details you can't
do it
by maximizing the marginal likelihood
over via cross-validation approach but
this is just point out that this is
something that is going to be a could be
a the kernel space is a quite rich so a
the basic currents that I show which
have some intuition can actually be
combined to just get a huge shoe of
kernels which actually this is where the
thinking happened because no one is
going to give you a kernel coming from
heaven you need to think about the
problem and to see how you model your
signal is not just doing model dot feet
this is in my opinion well in the
Gaussian process a methods the thinkin
happen selecting the kernel for example
how complex do you want it to be how
smooth a and so on and so forth and this
a rich theory about how these kernels a
can be constructed and say how different
spectral properties a would give
different a current for different type
of applications anyway I just want to
say this is a rich will reach space and
actually some products convolutions the
red Suns the red products you can get a
new kernel from all corners so just to
finalize a I want to just show how you
could do this in practice and there are
many ways of doing this a yesterday we
have seen talks with Stan also we had
with yourself I'm gonna show you how to
do it with circular and fertility the
resolution is not the best but I will
share this anyway so what is important
is that here have a periodic signal with
noise and the natural candidate for that
is just exponential a sine square
function and you can do this which I
could learn just by getting the kernels
and specifying the parameters and in
fact it learn you can define the bounds
so that a they can optimize for the best
parameters by maximizing the marginal
likelihood if you add a linear trend and
here the red line is specified where I
had like a training and the test set a
one way of model that is with
exponential kernel or a radial basis
function and here you take a really long
a scale so that these a let's say
captures the long-term movement so just
by adding these two you can model this
signal quite well yes so I can add yet
another seasonal component so that this
so that it mix with the other one in
such a way that the periods are
different and how do i model this new
signal will I just add another periodic
kernel and if I want to depending on how
I see the signal and we're like domain
knowledge unknown where your data is
generated from this is where you will
get inside of how to select the kernel
better and I don't think this is an easy
task but in some of public of these
applications you has been proven to be
quite successful it gives you even that
is not a parametric model you understand
what's happening if you really think
carefully about how to select the kernel
yeah so there are some computational
challenges so when people talk about
Gaussian process there's always this
question that in order to do infinite
you're going to use a essentially all of
the data because you need to have these
a huge a covariance matrix and then you
take some a inverse of certain matrices
so yeah that's that that's an important
topic in Gaussian processes but
nevertheless there are ways of doing
this in a clever way so try not to
invade the matrix but use some matrix a
factorization algorithm or do this by
approximation so that by itself is it's
acquired a interesting topic about some
reference I can just recommend the book
of Gelman and others on bayesian data
analysis they have a chapter devoted on
Gaussian process and they go really fast
on the definition of Gaussian process
but they spend most of the chapter
studying how kernels should be thought I
have written a little bit of experiments
about how to show this so that you can
play around with it and see how garson's
process let's say work from scratch so
from a basic linear regression to was
doing this a time series forecasting and
most of the basis of my talk actually
was trying to understand chapter 2 of
this book on Gaussian process for
machine learning or Fresno Zen and
Williams so this book I mean this
chapter has like I don't know 10 pages
or even less but it took me a decent
amount of time to run these experiments
and convince myself that what they
claimed make it sense so to say and this
is why I decided to to give this talk
yeah thank you very much if you have any
questions just let me know yeah thank
you okay any questions thank you you
only showed examples for one dimensional
two time series are there can you use
Gaussian processes to also fit two
dimensional or three dimensional time
series yeah actually a when I when you
see the definition on you pedia a of
Gaussian process they don't have a time
they can define Gaussian process in any
index set
so in principle a whenever if you have
an assignment of give me a
two-dimensional or n dimensional thing
and you can give me a normal
distribution then you can use it in this
context so yeah so Gaussian processes
are defined evil for a let's say more
dimensional in this space well thank you
for the talk I have one question
concerning the data that you were
fitting so mostly what I have seen that
you were fitting some some data which
can be fit also is standard Fourier
transform or the discrete value of free
transform why you I mean how good they
are fitting the data compared to the
Gaussian process mmm I haven't
experimented with that I did this for
myself so I always take the easiest
example
what I do know is that you can relate a
Gaussian process set with splines so you
could also try to do okay what because I
said I could also fit this with the
explained and for it's plain name you
need to add the degree of the smoothness
or how many nodes some in this book they
claim that Gaussian processes could be a
better a option there because you don't
need to select this but I guess it
depends on the application so I don't
have a concrete answer of why using
Gaussian processes against this one's
high so you have showed that the kernels
have a kind of algebra so you can add
them and stuff and then in applications
you figure out the best combination so
is there also a kind of basis within
these kernels I mean that the chest can
stick with the linear kernels order
polynomial kernels and then you know
that it will converge eventually or do
you have to let's say once you talk
about function spaces this becomes like
an infinite dimensional space right so I
guess you could try to use some Hilbert
space the composition but I don't think
this is gonna help you in practice
because yeah then you need to specify
okay how do i project these basis into
my concrete application what I've seen
is that people will go into the data and
try to see how it was generated get a
domain knowledge and from that for
example if you see that the amplitude
should be increases with the trend you
will multiply your square sine kernel
with radial basis kernel and you believe
that smoothness is going to be a
something part for you then they can
control it by adding up a rational
quadratic so yeah I guess it's more on
the data knowledge and domain expertise
rather than a general framework okay
last question
thank you just a short one here so just
discuss with the other Arthur Vincent on
the applicability of GPS outside
academia what is your opinion on GPS and
their use in in industry yeah so
actually I've used them I think they're
come really handy for modeling at least
in the applications that I've done
seasonality like strain seasonality
again you can use s client and yeah I
guess you in some sense also get a like
the credible interval for splines what I
like about a for example using guards
processes is that you can encode a lot
of information in the kernel with a lot
of intuition and you get incredible
intervals for it so if I need to remove
a strange seasonality which doesn't look
like a sine function I will just throw a
random process and model it like this
hey but I do know a lot of people using
a Gaussian process in in practice and
guess it for them the challenge is about
the computations but I do know they're
still quite active in industry okay
thank you very much one very interesting
talk and yeah another round of applause
[Applause]
[Music]